agents receive intelligence that the
true sons have taken over a detention
center and are using it to hold
prisoners suspecting a larger conspiracy
they are tasked with infiltrating the
facility and freeing the prisoners
[Music]
once the entrance had been located
agents make their way through the
tunnels although there were a few
flooded areas along the way they were
able to clear the blockages
entering through a breached wall they
found themselves in the laundry
after clearing out any true sons in the
area they continued to push through to
the center of the complex and into the
gym
by now the true Sons were quite aware of
the agent's presence and had put forward
the order to execute the prisoners being
held on site
Traders
the gym there was one prisoner that only
moments later would have been eliminated
had the agents not moved quickly
fending off another wave they would
catch up with the true Sun's Defector
thanks agent oh God I never thought I'd
say that but this is too [__] up
there's cities in the cells the doc's
been doing experiments on them you got
to get them out of here
moving towards cell block a the
Detention Center had now been put into
lockdown
agents would need to disable this if
they were going to reach the other
prisoners
once there they were greeted with
another wave of true Sons defending the
area
after they were cleared the control room
was located here the agents were able to
free a large number of the prisoners but
this is also when the agents would
intercept a hostile comps
God damn it we gotta protect Gonzalez
send reinforcements to the medical wing
Gonzalez
there's a prisoner on the Manifest named
Erica Gonzalez oh [__] her file says
she's an asymptomatic carrier be careful
agent
the agents managed to locate Gonzalez
but the true sons have called in
reinforcements to stop them from making
it to her
foreign
leader in command of this operation
would confront the agents and after
putting him down they would release
Gonzalez
don't hurt me I just want to go home I
didn't mean to hurt anybody
don't touch me
stay away
damn it God [__] damn it agent take
out that sniper
while they may have been unsuccessful in
rescuing Gonzalez they were able to risk
you a large number of civilians that the
true Sons were performing all sorts of
medical experiments on
goddamn pigs what happened we couldn't
make it past security the whole trip was
a [__] bust
probably for the best we need to show
them we're serious
I don't know that flying to New York to
burn a Christmas tree was the best plan
you're right that's why we're gonna do
the one at the mall
what mall
the mall in DC we are going to burn that
hybrid Abomination to the ground babe
that seems a little crazy don't [__]
call me crazy I thought you understood
what this means you know what they're
trying to do all this bioengineering is
going to kill us all this [__] is as
designed yeah I know it's just it really
seems like you're not thinking clearly
oh I'm clear I'm [__] Crystal you're
the one who doesn't want to see the
truth
Erica Gonzalez expresses frustration
over a failed plan involving security
Michael Lynn her boyfriend questions
what they're doing and if this is all
still worth it but Erica insists on
showing their seriousness by targeting a
mole in DC
Michael expresses concern calling it
crazy but Erica passionately believes
that bioengineering poses a deadly
threat and accuses Michael of not
understanding the truth
[Music]
state your name and age for the record
Erica Gonzalez
30 years old your boyfriend tells us you
were planning on setting fire to the
Christmas tree
is that right [__] week I'm sorry I
couldn't hear you could you please speak
up I said and my boyfriend is [__]
weak I never should have trusted him so
he was telling the truth yeah sure why
did you want to burn the Christmas tree
do you know what that [__] hybrid to
do to the local ecosystem it any of
those pine cones got loose and their
seeds were allowed to spread
I have no clue what kind of damage it
could do to the local floor on fauna oh
okay don't look at me like I'm crazy I'm
not [__] crazy you're all just too
[__] stupid to see what's really
happening
during an interrogation NSA operative
Mandy Masters asks Erica about her plan
to set fire to the Christmas tree
Erika expresses frustration with her
boyfriend and insists on the potential
danger the hybrid tree poses to the
local ecosystem
Mandy acknowledges Erica's concerns but
Erica is obviously feeling completely
ignored as she can't understand why
people fail to grasp the truth and the
severity of the situation
we're over capacity and we've got about
500 protesters that need to be housed
and processed we don't have the Manpower
or beds we could really use your help
you'll need to confirm with the staff on
site
pretty sure we've got an inmate with
that bug from New York she was there
during the outbreak she's showing
symptoms no but her boyfriend is they
quarantine him yeah if she isn't showing
symptoms we're probably in the clear
some people have a natural immunity to
this sort of thing I guess
I'd feel better if you checked with the
doc on site before you bring in your
protesters will do
in this interaction Martin Rivera a
prison guard asks Mandy for permission
to use her Detention Center to House and
process around 500 protesters due to
over capacity
Mandy expresses concern about a
potential inmate with a contagious bug
from New York but clarifies that the
inmate isn't showing symptoms
Martin assures her that some people may
have a natural immunity to this virus
and agrees to check with the on-site
doctor before proceeding with the plan
full quarantine what the hell happened
turns out that Eco Terrorist on the
psych war is one of those asymptomatic
carriers
major outbreak at the Detention Center
dock here has ordered a mandatory
lockdown and quarantine no one in or out
we're supposed to use the tunnels for
deliveries and set up negative air
Chambers and clean rooms at both ends
what about my prisoner moving her to a
secure location she'll be spending the
rest of the quarantine in a bubble to
try and isolate her from the rest of
genpop her boyfriend he died last week
just confirm the cause of death with
dollar flu don't call it that we gotta
kill those nicknames sorry
cause of death was complications from
modified smallpox variola Chimera that's
not really any better is it not really
ma'am
as expected there's now an outbreak in
the Detention Center
Kelly Archer another prison guard
informs Mandy about a major outbreak due
to an asymptomatic carrier an
eco-terrorist Erica Gonzalez who was
being held in the psych ward
as a result they have ordered a full
quarantine and lockdown using Tunnels
for deliveries and setting up negative
air Chambers and clean rooms
Erica will be moved to a secure location
in isolation as for a boyfriend he has
now died from the dollar flu
this isn't actually the first time we've
heard from Erica some of the NSA
recordings on her were heard during the
NSA site B13 classified assignment
unfortunately I don't see anything
interesting in the story that could
match up with the other things going on
in the current timeline
but I'm certainly not upset that Erica
was killed if she was rescued and would
somehow become part of the story again
and her recordings would follow a
similar path
you drive me bloody crazy
so you know small ones
with this mission complete that wraps up
the classified assignments that were
available in year one if you didn't get
to experience these I have a playlist
and in the description I'll have a link
to each of them
thank you very much for watching and
extremely smallest extreme remedia
[Music]
[Applause]